well this is nothing to celebrate and
it's yet more low growth on the back of
13 years of low growth and I think the
essential question many people today
will be asking themselves is do I feel
any better off now than I did 13 years
ago when this government started I think
the resounding answer that around the
country will be no I don't
reports today migration numbers could
hit a million how do you respond to that
I think we need to wait and see what
those figures are but I've seen that
speculation I think if they're anywhere
near that figure then it will show the
government's completely lost control we
need a managed approach here we haven't
got that we need to wait and see what
those figures are but
um you know it's like almost everything
else under this government there's no
plan there's no control and just like
everything else it seems like the system
is broken
uh more rail strike misery this weekend
which some claim is intended to
deliberately disrupt the Eurovision song
contest should the unions be able to
hold the public to Ransom in this way
and if you were prime minister how would
you have ended these rail streams well
these rail strikes been going on for a
very long time now and I don't want to
see them continuing I think the only way
to end them is for the government to get
into a room negotiate and settle this
dispute it's been going on a very very
long time the underlying causes are the
fact that many people working in the
railways fill their living standards
haven't improved over many many years
costs are going through the roof the
government's got to stop sitting on its
hands get around the table and sort this
one out
finally on the subject of Sue gray your
spokesman claimed she wasn't in the
government team handling requests from
the Privileges committee but we now know
she was in regular phone contact with
committee chair Harriet Army how is that
appropriate and is Sue gray a fit and
proper person to be your Chief of Staff
Sue gray is an excellent person her
reputation goes before her like all
senior civil servants now she's left the
Civil Service she has to go through a
process through a committee before she
starts any other role that process is
ongoing and we're just waiting for the
result now are you confident that
nothing was done wrong in that time I'm
confident that Sue gray is a woman of
incredible integrity and experience
and you know I'm not you know she's
going through the process because that's
what every senior civil servant has to
go through when they come out of the
Civil Service